[Musik]
essen
meister ist
[Musik]
seine liebste
wir wollen ein freihandelsabkommen das
wollen wir
wir wollen mit der eu befreundet sein
wir wollen aber nicht von der eu regiert
werden
wir wollen nicht von ihr kontrolliert
würden wir wollen ein europa des
handelns ein europa der zusammenarbeit
wir wollen ein verantwortliches europa
kein europa das versucht eine globale
supermacht zu sein
[Musik]
pascal am 8
bei vielen lief kampagnen ging es um den
glauben an großbritannien
wir wollen unsere eigene demokratie und
die eu bürokraten sollten uns nicht
sagen was zu tun ist
es geht darum an großbritannien zu
glauben
[Musik]
das gäste wie sowie vor und kamera
mein ex mann die beule mein name ist
mandy beule
ich bin 54 jahre alt und arbeite als
kosmetikerin in großbritannien
es habe in meiner jugend immer songs
geschrieben
es schien mir selbstverständlich nicht
durch musik auszudrücken
auch in der politik ich wollte einfach
spaß haben
ich dachte es wäre lustig die britische
flagge im hintergrund zu haben und davor
tanze ich mit blonder perücke
ich hätte nie gedacht dass das video so
beliebt wird
wir haben über 700.000 klicks auf
youtube
rasch machte diesen song sehr er spielte
ihn im dreck citybus während seiner
wahlkampftour
das war auch ziemlich toll wenn sie das
video gesehen haben haben sie bemerkt
dass es sich um eine low budget
produktion handelt ich musste mich sogar
klonen die union jack fahne im
hintergrund war ein kostenloser download
und bei der zeile sie haben unseren
gesamten fisch genommen wollte ich einen
fisch der auf einem transparenten
hintergrund schwimmt das kostete aber 50
dollar und ich war zu geizig angesichts
des erfolgs bereue ich es die 50 dollar
nicht gezahlt zu haben
tay kann oder will stand
[Musik]
denn schmecken
für mich ist die fischerei immer noch
eine große sache lande haben natürliche
ressourcen die sie nicht unbedingt
teilen
frankreich hat die alpen wir würden
jetzt auch nicht sagen dass die alpen zu
großbritannien gehören sollten und wir
unsere touristen dorthin schicken oder
deutsche kunden warum solltet ihr krone
an großbritannien abgeben
das vereinigte königreich ist eine insel
wir haben den fisch und jetzt müssen wir
in teilen das ist nicht fair
[Musik]
es stört mich nicht wenn die leute mich
beleidigen
es macht mir nichts aus wenn sie sagen
dass ich nicht singen kann
wenn sie sagen dass ich hässlich bin es
stört mich wirklich nicht
ich bin jetzt 54 jahre alt und kein
kleines mädchen mehr
ich kann das alles ab man lebt nur
einmal
also lasst uns leben lasst uns spaß
haben wenn man sich leidenschaftlich für
etwas interessiert warum sollte man
nicht darüber singen in großbritannien
ist die situation angespannt braig cit
befürworter und gegner beleidigen sich
gegenseitig wenn ich einen freund habe
der gegen den br- exit ist hat er das
recht dazu wichtig ist die debatte aber
plötzlich neigen alle dazu sich zu
beleidigen und das hilft wirklich
niemandem
lasst uns eine debatte führen lasst uns
zu einem vernünftigen standpunkt kommen
viele im parlament vertreten
unterschiedliche meinungen
bei den konservativen zum beispiel waren
nick bulls und enes aubry anhänger eines
manifests das den eu austritt vor
schrieb jetzt vertreten sie eine ganz
andere meinung
hier geht es um moral
natürlich dürfen sie eine andere meinung
haben
aber dann hätten sie nicht so sehr auf
dieses manifest bestehen dürfen
ich meine wenn sie dafür waren können
sie nicht einfach ihre meinung ändern so
täuschen sie die wähler sie haben
gelogen dadurch wenden sich die menschen
von der politik ab in großbritannien
haben noch nie so viele menschen wie
beim eu referendum gewohnt und wenn
diese menschen das gefühl haben dass die
demokratie nicht funktioniert dann
werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
wählen
[Musik]
momentan sorgt das eu projekt für viele
unruhen
ja die eu ist idealerweise ein
friedensprojekt aber das setzt voraus
dass alle in der eu die ansichten der eu
fanatiker teilen und das ist nicht der
fall
wir sehen wie populistische und
nationalistische parteien an macht
gewinnen wie sie gegen das europäische
projekt rebellieren
die menschen haben halt unterschiedliche
meinungen
gerade ist die eu kein friedensgarant
sondern vielmehr eine bedrohung für den
frieden
[Musik]
was die eu für mich bedeutet viele
vorschriften ein einfaches
freihandelsabkommen würde mir reichen
das ist alles was wir wollen handeln
wir wollen mit den ländern der eu
befreundet sein
wir sind europäer das ist eine
geografische tatsache europa und die
europäische union sollten nicht
verwechselt werden
wir wollen uns selber regieren
hier geht es um demokratie darum eigene
gesetze zu erlassen und sich nicht
gesetze diktieren zu lassen die hier
keiner will ich habe mein eigenes
unternehmen und muss sicherstellen dass
ich alle eu vorschriften befolgen
das kostet zeit und geld das ist
irgendwie verrückt ich exportiere doch
gar nicht in die eu warum sollte ich
also diese dummen vorschriften befolgen
wahres wirtschaftswachstum funktioniert
nur wenn wir alle eu vorschriften noch
mal überdenken
über 3600 neue gesetze wurden seit 2010
erlassen
schauen sie sich doch mal die eu cookie
richtlinie an dieses gesetz besagt dass
man die erlaubnis der nutzer einholen
muss um ein cookie auf ihrem pc zu
erstellen
statt eines angenehmen browser
erlebnisses gibt es aber nur pop up nach
pop up nach papa ich freue mich sehr
heute abend vor ihnen sprechen zu können
als judith parlamentskandidaten ins
dockten nord ich bin der judith
beigetreten weil ich mich für unsere
demokratie einsetzen wollte die youtube
hat im wahlkreis stockdorf einem
kandidaten gesucht und ich dachte warum
nicht es heißt ja immer wie youtube
wählt landet mit ed milliband im bett
oder wer tory welt landet mit nick clegg
im bett ich verspreche ihnen wenn sie
ins stocken youtube allen leuten sie
auch wirklich mit mir im bett
ich habe 20 prozent der stimmen bekommen
was ziemlich gut war
eigentlich hatte ich gehofft zu gewinnen
da war ich etwas enttäuscht aber ich
bleibe optimistisch und 20 prozent waren
[Musik]
judith geht jetzt einen ganz anderen weg
anstatt eine anti eu partei zu sein
haben sie ihren fokus auf andere themen
verlegt themen die ich nicht
unterstützen und mit denen ich nicht
einverstanden bin ich würde heute nicht
mit clip unterstützen
es ist nicht mehr die partei der ich
beigetreten bin ich finde es
beunruhigend dass die youtube offenbar
mehr in die richtung der british
national party geht es ist nichts was
ich unterstützen kann
deswegen bin ich gegangen ich werde
richtig ungemütlich wenn die leute
brachse befürworter rassisten
es hat wirklich nichts mit der rasse zu
tun mir ging es nie um einwanderung mir
ging es um demokratie
[Musik]
freiberg
die sonne ließ
[Musik]
ein zweites referendum und ein erneuter
eu-beitritt wären erschreckend
wahrscheinlich müssten wir mit einer
strafe und noch schlechteren bedingungen
rechnen
mein wunsch wäre ein modellwechsel ich
möchte riesa maze die nicht diesen dir
könnte ich nur zustimmen wenn die
backstop regelung ausfällt so dass wir
nicht auf unbestimmte zeit als
untergeordnete nation an den eu gebunden
sind
alles was wir wollen ist ein
freihandelsabkommen
wir wollen mit der er befreundet sein
wir wollen in der eben urlaub machen und
unsere haustiere mitnehmen die katzen
brauchen auf urlaub sie müssen sich auch
mal vom englischen wetter erholen ich
bin verrückt nach katzen ein eu-austritt
bedeutet nicht dass ich nicht mehr mit
meinen katzen verreisen kann ich möchte
nur bluttests machen und hätte
vielleicht einen erhöhten
bürokratieaufwand das wäre bei einem new
deal drechselt der fall
aber ich nehme lieber einen
administrativen mehraufwand in kauf als
dass menschen wie donald tusk und jean
claude juncker meine demokratie
unterwandert die folgendes praxis kann
man eigentlich so beschreiben
wenn du einen eimer wasser hass und
deine hand aus dem wasser ziehen hast du
ein paar wählen die nach einiger zeit
wieder flach werden
das gleiche gilt für den wechsel nach
einer kurzzeitigen störung kehrt die
normalität wieder an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
o
mit
[Musik]